mes chers collègues
nous entendons ce matin monsieur
françois de l'acquéreur
dans la ces présidents de section à la
cour des comptes sur l' enquête demandée
par notre commission en application de
l'article l eau 130 2-3-1 du code des
juridictions financières
sur le 100 % santé j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmise en direct sur
le site du sénat est disponible en vidéo
à la demande je salue ceux de nos
collègues qui participent à cette
réunion à distance de l'adoption de ce
dispositif notre commission avait
souhaité un suivi rigoureux de sa mise
en oeuvre afin d'en limiter les effets
de bord notamment en termes de qualité
du service rendu aux assurés d'évolution
des tarifs des complémentaires et de
coût pour la sécurité sociale
si j'ai bien lu votre enquête le bilan
ne peut être que provisoire mais je vous
laisse la parole pour nous livrer les
premières recommandations de la cour je
voulais sa parole monsieur le président
merci madame la présidente
alors je vais essayer de présenter
rapidement les principales conclusions
de cette enquête alors tout d'abord
quelques mots d'introduction pour
rappeler qu'il s'agissait d'une promesse
électorale de 2010 est président de la
république et donc que nous avons fait
ce bilan à votre demande à l'issue du de
quinquennat mais il faut souligner trois
points la première c'est que cette
réforme ne me remettait pas en cause
l'articulation entre assurance
obligatoire et assurances
complémentaires donc s'agit plus d'un
mouvement de paramètres on verra
lesquels que d'une réorganisation
du système la deuxième chose et ça a un
impact sur l'eau travaux c'est que là la
réforme a certes été mis en cause dans
en route dès 2018 mais elle n'est
intégralement en vigueur qu'à compter du
début 2021 est donc finalement le recul
n'est pas encore très très grand
d'autant que comme nous le verrons il ya
des problèmes de dispose de suivi de
disponibilité des données et troisième
point en plus cette réforme évidemment a
été percuté par la crise sanitaire et ce
qui fausse certaines des peu faussée
certaine remontée
alors nous avons abordé trois points
dans ce dans cette enquête la première
les objectifs de cette réforme le
deuxième ces résultats et le troisième
son coût et la façon dont on peut
piloter ce coup alors sur le premier
point des objectifs le constat de base
réalisé avant la réforme c'était qu'il y
avait des chaires reste à charge parfois
élevés dans trois champs qui sont
l'optique le dentaire les audioprothèses
un peu moins en optique puisqu'il y
avait déjà des offres sans reste à
charge avant cette réforme mais tout de
même tout à fait substantielle ce qui
pouvait souvent plusieurs enquêtes alors
les le petit tableau que vous avez
affiché résulte de travaux de la cnam et
la dss pour une part et d'une enquête
sur la santé européennes d'autre part à
des renoncements aux soins et ses
renoncements et s'avère plus fréquent
chez les personnes qui n'avaient pas de
complémentaire santé qui pourtant ne
sont pas tellement concerné par cette
réforme alors à quoi consiste-t-elle
elle consiste à créer des paniers de
différencier un panier 100% santé un
panier donc qui fait l'objet de
remboursements à 100% un panier libre au
contraire et un panier à reste à charge
maîtrisée et ses trois paniers ils sont
mises en oeuvre de façon assez
différenciées suivant les trois secteurs
il ya quand même une logique commune qui
est de plafonner les prix des biens
concernés et donc de rembourser de son
intégrale les biens en faisant la somme
des remboursements de l'assurance
maladie de base et de l'assurance
maladie complémentaire mais donc des
mécanismes différencier puisque pour ce
pour le domaine dentaire et auditif
on est parti des équipements déjà
consommé et on a supprimé les restes à
charge sur une partie d'entre eux
et en revanche
dans le domaine de l'optique
les organisateurs de f1 ont fait le
choix d'introduire de nouveaux produits
de définir de nouveaux produits sans
reste à charge à un niveau de prix très
inférieur à celui et des équipements
majoritairement consommer jusqu alors
donc c'est donc deux mécanismes très
différents
donc
les ce mécanisme bénéficie aux
ceux qui sont couverts par la
complémentaire de santé solidaire
puisque les équipements qui sont qui
donc qu'il y avait déjà des restes à
charge 0 évidemment puisque les
équipements qui sont proposés dans les
paniers 100% santé sont dans des gammes
en général supérieure à ce qu'ils se ce
dont ils bénéficiaient jusque avant mais
en contrepartie et ça et c'est ce qui
explique l'équilibré financier de la
réforme les remboursements de
l'assurance maladie obligatoire en
dehors de ces paniers 100% santé ont été
réduits en optique et le voilà et le
plafonnement de remboursement des 2
mètres a été abaissée par les
complémentaires santé c'est comme ça
qu'on arrive à un équilibre alors nous
allons passer au deuxième point qui est
celui des résultats sur le plan de la la
couverture alors nous avons regardé et
successivement les trois principaux
domaines donc d'abord dans le domaine
dentaire
sur donc des résultats plutôt
favorable puisque le panier sans reste à
charge et le panier à reste à charge
modéré donc souvenons nous des trois
paniers
représente maintenant une part très
majoritaire des actes qui sont réalisés
donc 55 % et 21 % donc c'est quand même
pas mal
deuxièmement on a constaté une
diminution des restes à charge 21 2% à
18 3 % en 2020 est encore bon on a des
chiffres anciens mais il peut être ça a
continué à baisser
ensuite
en revanche le nombre de patients
recourant aux soins on est on ne rompt
de il ya une augmentation
en 2021 mais
[Musique]
c'est encore encore incertain alors sur
les audioprothèses
il y a également des résultats
favorables puisque 40% des aides
auditives enduire 2021 ont été au
travers des paniers 100% santé qu' il y
a eu des munitions des restes à charge
du mois suivant les complémentaires
santé et qu' il ya eu une forte
augmentation du nombre de patients
puisque le nombre des d'audit if par
patient a augmenté
donc comme c'était écrit de 1,82 à 1,94
il restera encore à voir si ça tout ça
se
confirme dans la durée
il y à égal il y a tout de même nous
avons constaté que les prestations de
suivi n'était sans doute pas encore au
niveau de la consommation des du nom du
nombre de produits donc il faudra alors
évidemment ça prend un petit peu plus de
temps mais ça sera un des points à
surveiller
enfin le dernier secteur celle optique
alors c'est là que le bilan est le plus
contrastée mais comme je lai indiqué en
introduction de ce petit exposé ça peut
s'expliquer en partie par le fait qu'il
y avait déjà des offres favorable dans
le domaine de l'optique et que donc
l'apport du 100% santé a été
certainement plus faibles donc 17%
d'équipement avec au moins un point bien
du premier panier mais si on exclut les
bénéficiaires de la css c'est ça mais
que 9 % donc un résultat assez modeste
pas d'évolution du taux de recours et il
ya plutôt une augmentation de restes à
charge puisque évidemment comme
j'explique aux débuts là on a moins
rembourser ce qu'ils étaient à
l'extérieur du panier bras peut
rembourser le panier évidemment
les autres équipements ont augmenté de
présenter moi rembourser donc le reste à
charge a augmenté alors nous nous sommes
posé la question s'en remettre en
restant dans le cadre intellectuel delà
de la réforme ce qu'elle quel levier on
pourrait mobiliser pour la rendre plus
effective la première chose c'est que il
y a
probablement une communication qui
pourrait être renforcée puisque
finalement une personne sur deux
seulement a eu connaissance de cette
réforme d'après des enquêtes récentes et
puis que
lorsque la dgccrf a contrôlé les
établissements concernés elle s'est
aperçue que les trois quarts avaient au
moins une non conformité aux
prescription de de la réforme une autre
un autre levier qui pourrait être
mobilisé ses qui paraît tout à fait
essentiel c'est une évaluation de la
qualité des équipements qui serait à
mettre en place il y avait un
questionnaire sur la qualité des
équipements qui avait été qui avait été
prévu mais il n'a toujours pas vu le
jour et pourtant ça serait évidemment
très important de voir si les des
paniers puisque
le fond de la réforme c'est de
sélectionner un panier de biens est ce
que ce panier de biens et est adapté ou
n'est pas adapté voilà enfin le dernier
point mais qui n'est pas
spécifique au 100% santé c'est que le
l'obligation de proposer le tiers payant
intégral n'est pas bien respecté
voilà alors un jeu passe au dernier
volet de notre enquête qui est de savoir
combien ça coûte et à qui alors le
premier la première le premières choses
que nous avons essayé de comprendre en
regardant voilà c'est comment été
construits l'équilibré financier la
réforme comme celle indiquée au début
s'est construit comme un équilibre entre
des surcoûts évidemment sur le les
remboursements à 100% sur les
audioprothèses les prothèses dentaires
et puis des économies sur le moindre
remboursement et les baisses de prix de
remboursement notamment sur le secteur
de l'optique et la deuxième le deuxième
principe de construction
financière un petit peu de la réforme
c'était qu' il y avait une parité
des coûts prévisionnels entre le de
l'assurance maladie de base et
l'assurance complémentaire et donc le
coût prévisionnel qui avait été estimé
par le ministère de la santé 170
millions d'euros par an qui est donc la
résultante de ses coûts et ses économies
et à peu près dont 87 millions d'euros
pour la hem au 81 millions pour
la mc voilà alors la simple le ce que
nous avons quand même constater c'est
que ces hypothèses étaient
extrêmement
volontariste et que
voilà parce que le
gouvernement avait fait l'hypothèque
l'hypothèse que le les patients
recoureraient massivement au panier 100%
santé ce qui n'a comme on l'a vu était
le cas que dans une mesure beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus modeste
alors maintenant la deuxième chose nous
avons essayé de voir quel était le coût
réel par rapport aux estimations alors
la première chose alors là ça fait
partie du domaine sur lequel on a eu le
plus de difficultés
c'est que d'une part il ya un système de
suivi très décalé dans le temps qui fait
que
voilà notamment on a des
donc avec une mise en place complète
tardive de la réforme et ce décalage de
suivi on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres les plus récents ce qui était
un petit peu gênant pour l'anc est ce
qui semble se dégager néanmoins c'est
que il y à des dépenses inférieures aux
prévisions pour l'assurance maladie
obligatoire et mes supérieurs pour
l'assurance maladie complémentaire
comme c'est indiqué donc 127 millions
d'euros pour les mots entre 150 millions
attendus et
donc c'est effectivement le fait des
économies supérieures sur l'optique
qu'on a déjà vu dans les résultats de la
réforme est en revanche un surcoût
potentiellement important pour la mc et
là aussi c'est la deuxième limitation de
notre enquête comme nous n'avons pas
accès aux comptes des amitiés nous avons
dû prendre les statistiques qui nous ont
donné pour argent comptant voilà il
faudra sans doute regarder ça un peu
plus en détail par la suite et
l'assurant l'incident sur le secteur
économique et sans doute eu positive
notamment pour les audioprothèses dont
on a vu qu'il y avait une forte
augmentation de la consommation mais
c'est sans doute plus incertain dans les
autres domaines alors nous nous sommes
ensuite intéressé aux outils de
régulation qui étaient à la disposition
des pouvoirs publics et nous avons
constaté qu'il y avait d'abord peu
d'outils de régulation budgétaire et qu'
il y avait en plus était peu utilisé en
réalité et d'outils véritablement
intégrée à la réforme y en avait qu'un
c'est sûr les audioprothèses qui
permettait qui prévoyait une réduction
du prix limite de vente de ces
audioprothèses dès lors qu un certain
volume seraient excédés ce volume a été
dépassé puisque nous avons vu que le
secteur de l'audioprothèse était celui
pour lequel la réforme a été le mieux
marché mais on n'a pas fait les
résolutions de prix
dans le secteur nanterrienne clause de
rendez vous dans le cadre de la
convention dentaire mais qui n'a pas été
activée et puis il n'y a pas de
mécanisme dans le domaine de l'optique
voilà alors je termine cet exposé par
les recommandations que nous avons
inscrits à la fin de ce rapport à la
première qui est effectivement pour
essayer d'améliorer le suivi notamment
le suivi pour le résultat est aussi le
parrain le suivi financier c'est de
mettre en place un partage de données
entre l'assurance maladie obligatoire
les assurances complément ce qui
permettrait effectivement de
2,2 beaucoup mieux suivre ce qui se
passe pour le bénéfice de ceux qui
doivent piloter la réforme et mais
également pour les deux participants de
les deux financeurs le deuxième point
c'est de d'actifs de faire fonctionner
effectivement le mécanisme de régulation
dans le domaine des audioprothèses comme
je viens de l'indiquer et le troisième
point c'est de
[Musique]
mieux mettre en oeuvre le 100% santé
pour les
dans le domaine des chirurgiens
dentistes et de prévoir éventuellement
une clause pour
qui fonctionnerait en cas de dérapage
voilà madame la présidente
le président on voit bien que c'est un
rapport d'étape et c'est vrai pour
certains points je pense que le la crise
sanitaire a pu aussi bloqué bloquer des
initiatives si je pense aux
consultations autres
là je vais passer la parole à corinne
imbert qui est notre rapporteur de la
branche maladie est ensuite à berlin
jean mi
merci à la prison merci monsieur le
président pour votre présentation
j'ai plusieurs questions à vous poser
mais mais avant peut-être une remarque
sur le paradoxe de ce 100 % sentez vous
l'avez relever les les assurés qui n'ont
pas d'assurance complémentaire ne
bénéficient pas de cette réforme il ya
une annonce 100% santé mais clairement
il l'avait dit l'equilibre pas
remboursés par l'assurance maladie
obligatoire pas remboursés par
l'assurance complémentaire n'est pas
modifiée et donc les personnes qui sont
soit juste au-dessus des niveaux de
ressources pour bénéficier d'un c2s
l'assurance complémentaire santé soit
qui par choix ou parce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas un choix imposé avoir une assurance
complémentaire ne bénéficie pas du
système je crois qu'il faut évidemment
le rappeler et des classes moyennes sont
donc pénalisés et c'est la double peine
quand il ya une baisse de la prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie au delà
du du panier 100% santé vous l'avez
pointé dans votre votre rapport donc
c'est voilà c'est ce paradoxe qu'il
fallait qu'il fallait évidemment rappelé
deuxième point en terme de remarques
vous avez insisté donc sûr j'y
reviendrai sur la nécessité d'avoir un
suivi très sain de de cette réforme sur
la tension à la qualité
des prothèses qui doit être prise en
charge dans ce sens pour sa santé or et
au moment de la réforme au moment de la
décision évidemment nous étions en 2019
aujourd'hui nous sommes en 2022 nous
voyons globalement une augmentation du
coût des matériaux une augmentation donc
des produits finis et du des produits
finis et donc une difficulté aussi pour
un surcoût pour l'assurance
complémentaire d'abord il faudra et j'y
viendrai dans mes questions est-ce qui
aura pas un impact sur l'augmentation
des cotisations
et puis sur en descend par exemple vous
l'évoquez sur sur les audioprothèses
dans vos propositions en baissant le
tarif de remboursement de prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie si on a
un coût du produit fini qui est
augmentée à qualité égale et bien qu est
ce qui va se passer est ce qu'à un
moment donné on sera pas c'est peut-être
pas le cas pour les audioprothèses je
suis pas spécialiste du sujet mais est
ce qu'on sera pas au dessus
la valeur du produit fini au dessus du
prix de remboursement par l'assurance
maladie obligatoire ces points
d'attention et où on ne revient cette
notion d' équilibre qui est un équilibre
précaire entre et qualité coût pour
l'assurance maladie et coupes pour les
assurances complémentaires pour lesquels
il faudrait pas qu'ils et une
augmentation
des de la cotisation ensuite pour les
assurés et si par choix après des
assurés s'est même d'assurer renonce
malgré l'obligation pour les entreprises
de proposer une assurance complémentaire
à leurs salariés renoncent à l'assurance
complémentaire on peut plus parler de
100% santé puisque là on a un surcoût
pour les assurés voilà une remarque fin
des romains que général que je tenais à
a précisé à la suite de votre
présentation alors peut-être que dans
mes deux questions j'y reviendrai
et je reviendrai sur juste une phrase
dans votre rapport page 19 sur lequel je
voulais avoir votre votre sentiment donc
sur bilan est il celui de la réforme
dont je vous ai dit elle la réforme ne
bénéficient que très partiellement
personnes voire ne bénéficie pas aux
personnes ne disposant pas d'une
couverture complémentaire donc dans quel
dans quelle mesure un ce stade des riez
vous que la réforme a atteint sa cible
en réduisant les inégalités dans l'accès
au soin parce que c'est bien ce qu'on
voulait nous faire croire avec un
affichage 100% santé et le renoncement
aux soins des populations les plus
fragiles et comment faire en sorte que
ces objectifs soient mieux atteint avec
toujours évidemment en arrière pensée
l'équilibré des comptes des comptes
sociaux
comment le suivi de l'incidence de la
réforme sur le secteur de l'assurance
maladie complémentaire petit peut-il
être renforcée vous l'avez dit vous
n'avez pas accés on vous prenez pour
argent comptant ce qu'on vous dit une
haie hausse des primes à part est elle
justifiée par la santé financière des
organismes complémentaires qui ont
engendré en 2020 d'importants excédents
il y aura évidemment le débat entre
assurance complémentaire privée et
mutuelles mais la question
mérite d'être posée
les dépenses induites par la réforme se
sont avérés inférieurs aux prévisions
pour l'assurance maladie obligatoire
mais largement supérieur aux prévisions
en revanche par l'assurance maladie
complémentaire ce déséquilibre s'il
s'avérait structurels devraient conduire
à une redéfinition du partage de
l'effort en a entre assurance maladie
obligatoire et en assurance maladie
complémentaire
vous vous êtes appuyé dans le cas de vos
travaux sur les conclusions du comité de
suivi mis en place par le plfss pour
2010 9
ces structures vous parait-elle adapté
aux besoins de suivi vous semble-t-elle
avoir eu un rôle efficace jusque là dans
le pilotage de la réforme j'ai cru
comprendre dans vos propos que non et je
suis d'accord avec vous pour
qu'il y ait besoin d'avoir un suis très
fan la réforme parce que les choses
évoluent très vite notamment sur le plan
technologique sur la poursuite de la
réforme et ses évolutions possibles une
actualisation des paniers de soins doit
être engagée cette année elle pourrait
notamment produire une diminution du
prix limite devant des ados dit yves
préconisé dans votre rapport et je
reviens
ma remarque je faisais en préambule donc
la révision doit elle selon vous
poursuivre d'autres objectifs les
paniers notamment doivent-ils être
enrichi pour les fortes corrections en
optique les piles pour les
audioprothèses où les prothèses en
céramique pour les molaires
une série de réunions avec les
organismes complémentaires devaient être
programmé en 2022 afin de lever les
obstacles techniques à la mise en oeuvre
du tiers payant intégral avez vous pu
constater au cours de vos travaux des
avancées en la matière si le législateur
et s'était saisi de cette question en
2021 la disposition a été toutefois
censuré par le conseil constitutionnel
le recours à la loi vous semble-t-il
nécessaire enfin quel regard portez vous
sur les propositions d'extension du 100%
santé à de nouveaux secteurs tels que
les prothèses capillaires et semelles
orthopédiques l'orthodontie formulées
par la caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie dans son dernier rapport charge
des produits une telle extension vous
parait-elle réaliste à court ou moyen
terme compte tenu des difficultés dans
le pilotage économique du dispositif est
encore une fois attention quelque part h
et peut-être employer un mot pas
politiquement correct mais attention à
ne pas mentir aux français sur la
formulation du 100% santé je vous
remercie
donc c'est vous souhaitez répondre tout
de suite où on prend la question à
monsieur oui vous allez y à pas mal de
questions peut-être je vous laisse
répondre d'emblée à et hans et merci
madame la présidente nous allons pas
nous allons répondre à deux avec avec
erwan sa main qui a été c'est lui qui a
fait le rapport alors vous d'abord vous
avez vous êtes inquiétés du fait que les
les personnes qui ne sont pas couverts
par une complémentaire de santé n'ont
pas bénéficié de cette réforme du 100%
santé effectivement c'est un point
c'était inhérent à la construction même
de cette réforme alors dans notre
enquête nous n'avons pas
nous n'avons pas cherché à
sortir du cadre intellectuel de cette
réforme comme je lui ai rappelé tout à
l'heure mais néanmoins nous avons
bien pointé ce fait
su pour les pour les personnes couvertes
par la complémentaire santé est
effectivement les premiers résultats
montrent que globalement c'est positif
mais évidemment pour celles qui ne sont
pas couvertes par une complémentaire qui
sont plutôt les chômeurs les inactifs en
âge de travailler les jeunes adultes
des résultats sont il faut il faut
analyser ça entre ceux qui sont couverts
par la complémentaire santé solidaire
pour lequel évidemment il n'y a pas eu
de dégradations il ya même eu comme je
les ai expliqué il ya eu il ya une
légère amélioration de la situation du
fait que les paniers de soins qui leur
sont maintenant proposés sont plus
favorables et en revanche pour les
autres évidemment il n'y a eu aucune
aucune amélioration alors comme je le
disais dans le cadre de ce rapport nous
n'avons pas
nous n'avons pas épiloguer sur ce point
là mais lors d'un rapport que nous avons
publié l'année dernière qui justement
s'interroger sur l'articulation entre
l'assurance complémentaire et
l'assurance de base mais que nous avions
fait pour l'assemblée nationale nous
nous avions proposé plusieurs scénarios
d'évolution de l'articulation entre ces
deux assurances alors soit le
décroisement des risques soit le panier
soit le bouclier sanitaire soit le
renforcement de la régulation et qui
pourrait
tendre à améliorer cette cette situation
alors peut-être sur la deuxième question
sur la deuxième question donc 1 comme
vous l'avez vous avez pu le voir donc la
cour recommande effectivement de mettre
en place un partage des données entre
l'assurance maladie obligatoire et
d'assurances complémentaires il faut
savoir qu'il existe d'ores et déjà dans
le plan technique une disposition qui
prévoit justement dans le cadre du
système national des données de santé
que les organismes complémentaires met à
disposition un échantillon représentatif
des données de remboursement par cette
disposition et qui n'appliquent et nous
semble donc que utile justement de
mettre en place cette disposition ce qui
permettrait effectivement d'obtenir
justement les données nécessaires ne se
passe que de suivi pour être aussi
l'occasion d'ailleurs de d'enrichir
finalement peut-être cette disposition
une façon tenté uniquement de données de
nature financière mais peut-être de
données sur les garanties elle même
offerts par les différentes
complémentaire santé afin de justement
de pouvoir vraiment obtenir un suivi fin
de la réforme que ce soit sur la
question du coût mais aussi des
prestations associées
sur la question de la situation
financière des complémentaires santé
comme vous l'avez vu et justement à
l'absence de 7,2 cette disposition nous
ne pouvons disposer que de données qui
sont finalement un peu anciennes
si on regarde le dernier rapport de la
drees sur la situation financière des
complémentaires santé donc sont des
données 2020 elles font effectivement
état de d'excédent un peu supérieure en
2020 par rapport à 2010 neuf puisque son
l'adresse celle ci était de l'ordre de
637 millions en 2020 par rapport à 462
millions en 2019 néanmoins il est quand
même difficile d'en tirer des
conclusions parce que d'une part il
s'agit d'une moyenne donc évidemment les
assurés sont assurés de
d'organismes différents dont la
situation financière est différente et
on ne sait pas quelle est véritablement
la situation financière de ces
différents organismes complémentaires en
2021 donc il est difficile de vous
répondre sur ce point tant qu
effectivement il ne sera pas possible
d'obtenir des informations financières
de façon à actualiser
alors sur la question sur le
déséquilibre des dépenses entre amo et
amc alors effectivement ça s'éteint
c'est un fait
alors la question c'est est ce que il
faut
redéfinir du coup les paramètres de la
réforme et le partage des efforts alors
nous nous sommes pas prononcés sur ce
point mais ce que nous avons quand même
essayer de montrer c'est que
cette réforme et c'est d'ailleurs aussi
une des difficultés de du suivi de la
réforme cette réforme elle est insérée
dans des relations plus large entre
l'assurance maladie de base et
l'assurance maladie complémentaire
par exemple sur le
est par exemple le
sur le domaine dentaire
l'assurance a dans le cadre de la
convention dentaire qui a embarqué un
certain nombre de dispositions de la
réforme il y avait également des
investissements tout à fait considérable
de l'assurance maladie obligatoire pour
des soins conservateurs il y en avait
pour 635 millions d'euros et puis il y
en avait alors qu'il y en avait que 180
millions d'euros pour les
complémentaires santé et donc simplement
ce que je voudrais souligner c'est que
si on devait toucher à l'équilibré entre
complémentaire santé et base il faudrait
sans doute faire ça de façon plus
globale
peut-être dans le cadre de la nouvelle
convention dentaire le jour où elle sera
renégocié
sur la qui ont du comité de suivi qui a
été mis en place par la loi de
financement pour 2019 alors nous avons
évidemment eu accès à l'ensemble des
documents qui sont produits pour
l'administration c'est assez classique
et évidemment les conclusions du comité
de suivi font partie de ces documents à
paris nous semble que sous comité
présente certes en deux points utiles ne
serait-ce que de permettre justement
différentes parties prenantes d'être
informées de l'avancée de la réforme
mais aussi de pouvoir aborder en séance
et les différents points qui peuvent
poser difficulté alors il est vrai
néanmoins que ce qu'ont pu nous dire un
certain nombre d'acteurs c'est qu'il
trouvait que ce comité parfois peut-être
un peu trop descendants et donc
insuffisamment participatif et ne
permettant pas justement peut-être
d'aborder toutes les difficultés en tout
cas de véritablement de mettre au pot
commun finalement l'ensemble des données
ou en tout cas des points déprendre
intérêts des différentes parties
prenantes et puis le point je pense que
le point le plus dur ou le frein le plus
important il est toujours le même et
finalement c'est celui de la question
des données actualisées sur notamment
sur le point de vue financier qui
permettent difficilement finalement le
suivi de la réforme or c'est bien le le
sens premier de ce comité
alors sur et si on maintenant sur
l'enrichissement éventuelle des paniers
nous avons vu au cours de notre enquête
que notamment la caisse nationale
d'assurance-maladie commencé à nourrir
ses dossiers sur cette question là
notamment sur la question de fortes
corrections optiques de piles pour les
audioprothèses des prothèses en
céramique pour les molaires comme vous
voulez les
expliquer néanmoins nous n'avons dans
notre rapport nous avons pas été jusque
là notamment parce que
nous avons comme j'ai essayé de
l'expliquer nous n'avons pas encore les
éléments pour tirer un bilan
véritablement complet et notamment un
point qui nous paraît tout à fait
important c'est ces enquêtes auprès des
des patients pour voir pour essayer
d'évaluer si le panier déjà actuelle est
adaptée et il nous semblerait
il nous semblerait qu'il faudrait
d'abord
procéder à ce bilan
avant de faire des extensions et c'est
parce que peut-être que on s'apercevra
qu'il ya d'autres évolutions qu'il faut
faire notre préconisations c'est quand
même d'abord de de savoir exactement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sur la wii
sur les questions du tiers payant
intégral un lord ce que nous pouvons
savoir donc comme vous le savez dans le
cadre de nos procédures y ait toujours
une phase de contradiction avec les
administrations pour que celles ci
puissent prendre connaissance de notre
instruction et des conclusions qu'elle
nous sommes parvenus
il n'y a pas eu de remontées
particulières sur la question du tiers
payant intégral donc a priori semblerait
que donc le cycle de réunions que vous
êtes vieux que vous évoquez pardon n'est
pas donnée jusqu'à présent des faits
probants et donc comme comme nous
l'indiquions dans le rapport il nous
semble que si effectivement la situation
venait à se pérenniser ici l'ensemble
des parties prenantes ne parvenez pas à
avancer sur cette question
il semble qu'effectivement seules
dispositions de nature législative
pourrait permettre de lever les blocages
éventuellement constaté
précisa oui juste une petite remarque
que je lui avais dit dans mon propos
liminaires et j'ai oublié de le
mentionner mais vous avez écrit monsieur
le président les soins conservateurs en
matière dentaire est une bonne chose et
page 19 de votre rapport aux miens un
tableau sur les mesures complémentaires
visant à améliorer l'accès aux soins et
vous évoquez les délais d'accès aux
soins
dans le domaine de l'optique de cette
terre auditifs et une petite phrase à la
fin de septembre en terre semble à ce
stade - concernés par ces problèmes
d'accès juste vous dire que c'est pas
franchement de le sentiment qu'on a sur
un certain nombre de territoires et que
avec voyez l'accès aux dentistes en tout
cas pour ce qu'il faut constamment
département je peux vous dire que c'est
pas si simple que ça bien au contraire
comment
oui il faut voir on a des départs en
retraite et pas de pas de nouveau dans
tison alors que les soins conservateurs
était pertinent terme de meilleure prise
en charge par l'assurance maladie si on
n'a pas accès et je vois là sur le juste
une petite remarque sans être
désagréable et je pense que c'est pas
partout la réalité merci à vous
alain jaumier pour compléter oui merci
non mais vraiment rock d'abord corinne
imbert a posé une série de questions
pertinentes et vous y avez répondu mais
j'aurais voulu km2 de deux précisions
une d'abord sur le tiers payant intégral
j'ai bien entendu votre réponse mais ce
dispositif il est particulièrement
important si on veut que le 100% santé
contribue à améliorer l'accès aux soins
vu les le vu les coûts en ce qui
concerne optique dentaire et
audioprothèses pourquoi est il mal
respectée est ce que c'est parce que la
procédure est trop complexe
voilà on sait que parfois les tiers
payant sont difficilement appliquée
parce que les professionnels acte du
fait que la procédure de recouvrement
est trop longues ou trop compliqué ou
est ce parce que il ya des indicateurs
de non respect des tarifs et en
subsidiaire vous avez répondu que les
difficultés sur le tpiy relèverait du
domaine législatif mais sur ces
questions non ce ne serait pas ce ne
serait pas le cas donc voilà j'aurais
voulu vous nous apportiez un peu plus de
pression sur cette question puis la
deuxième est un peu d'ordre général et
fait écho à beaucoup de questions et aux
cadres cacace a rappelé corinne imbert
c'est que au fond on cherche l'objectif
c'est quand même que sur ces trois
thématiques notre population et un
meilleur accès à ses prestations santé
qu'il n'est actuellement alors dites moi
si je me trompe mais à votre bilan
partiel on a le sentiment que sur
l'audioprothèse c'est ce qui se passe
qui lie à une progression très nette et
qui répond à un besoin de santé la
population on a moins l'impression que
c'est le cas sur l'optique est ce que je
me trompe ou est ce que il y à un
mésusage qui est facilité par ce
dispositif des prestations en optique
il répond
alors sur la première question
concernant le tiers payant intégral or
il n'y a pas de difficultés de non
respect des tarifs en tout cas les
contrôles qui ont été opérées notamment
par la cnam ne permettent pas de
démontrer une difficulté de cette nature
par contre comme vous le soulignez
effectivement les difficultés sont
d'ordre multifactorielles il ya
notamment un sujet qui qui est née
notamment avec la réforme qui est celle
de la granularité des données qui sont
transmises entre entre le patient et des
organismes complémentaires via notamment
les opticiens il ya une question de ce
que la nomenclature a été revue elle
s'est très nettement affiné et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une interrogation sur sur
le degré de finesse des données qui doit
être transmise les opticiens en fait
trop fusant de donner des informations
très précises les organismes
complémentaires considérant que sans ces
données elles ne peuvent pas mettre en
oeuvre la gestion du risque qui pourtant
partie intégrante de leur métier donc ça
serait partie des sujets qui freinent
notamment sur le point de l'optique la
question tiers payant intégral alors il
ya aussi effectivement peut-être d'écrin
coût des réticences des professionnels
de santé notamment liée à la question du
délai de remboursement et ça c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles dans
l'amendement qui avaient été proposées
il y a un an c'est cette question de la
durée de la nature des données aussi qui
doit être transmise était prévu dans cet
amendement doudou cette réponse
législative
assez assez différentes difficultés
alors sur la ddt yem question et sur le
meilleur accès aux prestations tout à
fait vous avez la bonne vision des
choses sur les l'audioprothèse c'est là
où il ya le taux de recours le plus
important à ce panier il ya une
augmentation totale du nombre de
personnes qui ont acheté des
audioprothèses qui se sont équipés etc
et puis à une diminution de restes à
charge donc c'est vraiment le domaine
dans lequel les objectifs de la réforme
ont été le mieux satin et je ne les ai
pas dit tout à l'heure dans mon petit
propos de ma petite présentation mais
ces présents dans le rapport à tel point
que nous nous sommes interrogés sur la
pertinence de certains recourent à des
équipements et notamment on a remarqué
qu' il y avait presque systématiquement
les deux oreilles qui étaient couvertes
alors que parfois il ya besoin que d'une
oreille et xsara et donc que nous avons
recommandé qu'on aille regarder un petit
peu qu est-ce qui c'était qu'est ce qui
s'était passé dans le domaine des
audioprothèses dans le domaine de
l'optique effectivement
il y a un taux de recours qui beaucoup
plus faible alors comme je le disais
quand même au début il y a entre
guillemets peut-être une circonstance
explicative c'est que contrairement aux
autres domaines dans le domaine de
l'optique qui avait déjà des offres
qui permettait d'avoir des règles fait
sascha 0 et déjà des offres qui
permettait d'avoir des prix réduits au
travers des contrats responsables au
contrat de la css au travers voilà et
donc le l'apport de la réforme était
beaucoup plus faible donc ça peut
s'expliquer de cette façon là mais en
revanche
le le les la façon dont financièrement
la réforme a été construite c'est à dire
que on à concentrer les moyens sur les
paniers 100 % et au contraire on a
comme on dire diminuer les prises en
charge sur le reste fait que sur
l'optique comme il ya eu peu de recours
à ces paniers sont % le 2 facteur a fait
que globalement le
comment dire le taux de restes à charge
a nettement augmenté sur l'optique donc
effectivement le bilan est nettement
moins favorable ce dans ce domaine
germanier merci même la présidente très
courte une question qui concerne les
contrôles et oui après avoir travaillé
trois mois sur les contrôles du
contrôleur en ehpad j'ai aussi une
attention particulière sur le suivi que
vous
marquez comme quelque peu et en
améliorer et les contrôles donc
l'exemple que vous donnez sur les
audioprothèses qui sont parfois à donner
sur les deux oreilles et alors qu'il
suffirait médicalement d'en avoir qu'une
quels sont les moyens de contrôle qui
avec vous
dans voilà
en capacité de mettre en place pour être
conforme à ce qui est demandé contrôle
il s'agit du service médical de la de de
l'ès 2 il s'agit du service médical de
la cnam 1 c'est vous qui suivent voilà
nous avons
chose a été fait fin ça c'est clair mais
bon là autre côté on est quand même
qu'au tout début nous nous appelons
plutôt est ce que ça se développe
et pour terminer est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous attribuez à la crise dans un
peu la difficulté du départ sur quels
points
peut-être est-ce qu'il ya des poids
d'abord est-ce qu'il y en a pas
ou est ce qu'il ya en effet des points
particuliers pourraient dire on pourrait
dire là peut-être la crise à jouer alors
il ya un premier point qui est quand
même évident c'est que
on n'a parlé que de la crise et donc on
n'a pas du tout parlé du 100% santé et
donc la méconnaissance de la réforme que
j'ai rappelé que nous critiquer que nous
avons documenté dans le rapport il se
rappelait 12 heures elle est sans doute
largement liée à ça et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous préconisons que
l'on a maintenant que la crise est quand
même large partie derrière nous que l'on
renforce l'effort d'information dans ce
domaine ça c'est le premier point
sur le deuxième point
alors là c'est moins directement le la
comment dire la connaissance de la
réforme et serra mais ce qui est comme
jeu comme nous l'avons souligné on n'a
pas mis en place de dispositif de suivi
spécifiques
de notamment financier de la réforme est
donc
dans ces années où il s'est tellement
passé
de chose on
il est très difficile de voir ce qui
relève de la réforme du 100% santé et ce
qui relève des bouleversements quand
même de la consommation médicale qui a
été occasionné par par la crise et le
dernier point enfin c'est que
effectivement ces bouleversements ont eu
certainement mais évidemment pour la
raison que je viens d'indiquer il est
difficile de dire dans quelle mesure ils
ont certainement changerait
les les résultats en termes de
consommation de soins
on sait très bien que pendant la crise
il ya eu moins de recours aux soins que
sauf ça que qu'habituellement parce que
les gens sont restés chez eux parce
qu'il était plus difficile d'avoir accès
au système de soins et ça a certainement
eu un impact sur la réforme du sud pour
60 et simplement nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de dire exactement ce qui est
précisément ce qu'il en est donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle il ya il
probablement il sera voilà l'année 2022
sera très importante pour avoir une
vision beaucoup plus précise sur ce
qu'il en est de la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme à bien
isabelle boinot
merci
merci madame la présidente merci
messieurs pour l'ensemble de ses
réponses et surtout de ce rapport et moi
je souhaite vraiment que ce soit mon
prolongée parce que en réalité la crise
a quand même beaucoup bouleverser les
choses d'une part pour gérer la
population qui reste quand même confiné
qui n'a pas eu effectivement toujours
connaissance pleinement de ces
dispositifs encore que il y en a qui
trouve toujours moyen de connaître les
choses mais bon on peut pas dire que
c'était l'idéal pour faire une
évaluation
par ailleurs je pense qu'il faut
regarder très précisément ce que ça a pu
avoir comme impact non seulement sur la
population la première visée puisque
l'intérêt c'était de mieux soigner mieux
équipés
la population mais de l'autre côté il
faut regarder aussi des professions
liées c'est à dire comment les choses se
sont passées au niveau des dentistes des
audioprothésistes des opticiens et et
tout doit être à mon avis dans la nuance
et la mesure parce que moi j'ai eu aussi
des opticiens qui m'ont dit mais on est
contrôlé on est contrôlé même et c'est
infernal alors ils sont pas contre le
contrôle mais d'un autre côté quand ils
habitent en ville et qu'ils ont une
certaine clientèle ils peuvent pas non
plus faire le 100 % santé au niveau
qu'il leur est demandé ça dépend de là
où vous êtes et donc voilà il faut
regarder un petit peu ça et il faut
regarder dans l'optique si on n'a pas
non plus
mis en danger des entreprises françaises
qui fabrique des lunettes parce que ça
c'était notre si notre question quand ça
s'est mis en place dans le jura
notamment on avait été interrogé par des
entreprises est plutôt que d'aller à
chercher des lunettes en chine parce
qu'il faut effectivement faire
absolument le 100% je sentais est-ce
qu'il faut pas regarder ce qui se passe
aussi dans nos territoires et on est
aujourd'hui tous très attachés à la
production nationale sur les
audioprothèses moi je pense
qu'effectivement on était parti d'un
équipement très loin puisque le petit
qu'est donc la montée en charge avait
fait plus forte mais après ce que
j'entends aussi des audioprothèses c'est
que la qualité des produits qu'on peut
donner pour le 100 % santé n'est pas
forcément en adéquation avec les
problèmes identifiés sur le patient et
que c'est un vrai problème parce qu'ils
reviennent continuellement dans les
magasins enfin auprès des professionnels
pour essayer de 2 comment de mettre
l'appareil au bon niveau mais avec des
difficultés parce que justement ces
produits là sont pas en capacité
d'apporter une qualité suffisante sur
les dentistes les dentistes aujourd'hui
d'après ce que je vois me faudrait que
vous regardiez justement au lieu de
faire de la prothèse ils font de linley
hong lei et ça coûte très très cher et
donc regarder en fait sur l'activité
d'un dentiste d'une année avant le 100 %
santé ce qu'ils faisaient et ce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui parce que je pense que
là ya ya ya ya des petites choses qui
sont à corriger en tout cas
la quantité le fait de cibler le plus de
personnes dans la population qui ont
besoin d'être équipé ça s'est très très
bien mais au détriment de la quantité
voyons aussi la qualité sans perdre de
vue les professionnels de tous ces
domaines qui ont aussi besoin de gagner
leur vie et pas toujours d'être
forcément contre les contrôles et enfin
contre les oui mais mais mais attention
pas il faut de la mesure et de la nuance
merci
monsieur de la grosne hier je vous
laisse répondre merci alors
effectivement alors
n'avons rien à redire à ce que on
remarque que vous avez faite sur sur le
l'impact sur les professions nous avons
essayé de regarder ce qu'il en était
nous avons quand même vu que
notamment je crois que c'était dans le
secteur de l'optique on a eu
l'impression que le panier 100% chanter
était peut proposer au patient et que
voilà ça peut être ça peut être
contribué aussi à jouer au fait que le
la réforme avait avait peu avait eu peu
d'impact
alors nous nous sommes posé la question
de l'impact sur les entreprises
sur les entreprises et c'est vrai que et
notamment nous avons remarqué qu' il y
avait eu une formulation
delà du mécanisme de la réforme
différente suivant qu'on était en
audioprothèses et en et en dentaire et
puis en optique d'autre part où là on a
choisi de développer un des produits
nouveaux avec des prix avec des prix
très bas et c'est vrai que probablement
dans ce domaine les vu le prix
qui a été fixée les lunettes sont
probablement apporter en très large en
travers je partis voilà
voilà alors après vous avez souligné
qu'effectivement c'est c'est une des
conclusions principales de notre rapport
c'est qu'il faut absolument arriver à
se poser la question de l'adéquation des
produits qui ont été encouragés par la
réforme aux véritables besoins avant de
voir de l'avant de faire évoluer cette
réforme sinon on va on va bâtir sur des
sur des bases qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas assurés voilà ce que je pouvais
dire bien à milan souhaite à une
question oui merci même présente j'ai
j'ai écouté avec une certaine attention
et votre rapport essayer les
interventions des uns et des autres et
j'ai des sentiments en vous écoutant que
finalement c'est extrêmement compliqué
comme système il y a d'un côté là et
mode autre côté les amc chacun
intervenant à différents niveaux
avec donc finalement des frais de
fonctionnement qui doivent être
considérables pour des remboursements
qui doivent être minime n'y at il pas un
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un seul
financeur
plutôt que de multiples financeurs qui
entraîne la confusion pour tout le monde
y compris d'ailleurs pour la cour ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup
mais ces présidents c'est alors c'est
comme je les dis c'est une question que
nous n'avons pas traité dans le cadre de
ce rapport mais que nous avions examiné
dans le cadre de notre rapport sur les
complémentaires de santé de l'année
dernière et effectivement on voit bien
que la caractéristique de notre système
avec deux financeurs qui interviennent
concurremment sur les mêmes risques pour
tous les risques est particulièrement
complexe d'autres pays européens qui ont
également un système avec une assurance
de base et une assurance complémentaire
ne sont pas construits comme ça par
exemple l'allemagne les l'assurance de
base et spécialisés entre guillemets sur
un panier de soins et les assurances
complémentaires sur spécialisé sur
d'autres prestations ce qui fait que les
financeurs sont chaque financeurs et
responsable finalement sur son domaine
de remboursement ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez nous évidemment cela induit une
très forte complexité cela induit un
doublement des frais
d'administration et cela induit des des
très grosses difficultés lorsqu'il
s'agit de pinon de financer une réforme
comme ça qui fait intervenir deux
acteurs parce que les dés comment dire
là la transmission la dea des données se
fait extrêmement mal et c'est d'ailleurs
une des recommandations c'est d'essayer
quand même de l'améliorer et c'est vrai
que là si on voulait véritablement
améliorer les choses il faudrait
s'interroger sur l'articulation entre la
science et dans ce rapport
les rappeler tout à l'heure nous avions
fait quelques avions dessiné des n'avons
pas pris sur notre responsabilité le
fait de dire il faut faire ceci ou cela
mais nous avions essayé de dessiner des
scénarios contrastés d'évolution
pour essayer de résoudre cette question
là qui est effectivement un des grands
problèmes structurels de notre
protection sociale en matière de
maladies très bien moi j'avais un
dernier point et on l'a évoqué avec toi
pour tourner la semaine passée sur le
problème des centres de santé dentaire
avec les abus qui peuvent exister bon je
pense que vous n'êtes pas rentrer dans
le détail de qui faisait quoi mais je
pense que ce sera un point de vigilance
quand même à voir comment ça se passe
dans ces centres là et l'autre point
c'est bon on est d'accord sur un effet
un reste à charge de prothèses soit le
moins élevé possible mais l'essentiel la
prévention de la prothèse quand même le
soin
sauf sauvegarde de prothèses nécessité
par des traumatismes autres et il faut
quand même
axé beaucoup aussi sur sur le soin le
soin dentaire qui prévient les protéger
voilà il n'y a pas d'autres questions je
vais vous demander d'autoriser la
publication de ce rapport et je propose
que le rapporteur du rapport pour la
position soit corinne imbert en charge
donc de ce sujet comme apportant la
branche maladie qui est opposé à cette
publication
est favorable donc très bien voilà
merci merci monsieur le président est et
à tous les deux pour pour se présenter
c'est un devoir et une prochaine aux
jeunes rencontre même si